I know that you got into stand-up
because friends of yours this was not
the plan no this was not the plan for
you I don't think I really had a real
plan Kona those are my favorite people
didn't have a real plan I listen when I
started college first of all you got to
know I got in college
I didn't realize that until the first
semester I was like oh these
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
and then they was like oh you know you
gotta pick a major major what's that
it's like what do you want to be oh okay
all right let's play all right so that's
that's how as serious as you should take
that question who knows at 18. yeah and
I was like okay so I want to be a lawyer
okay that lasted a week I got all those
[ __ ] books one to one class and this
[ __ ] was like 25 cases a day you
have to have read and analyze and I was
like you can go [ __ ] yourself right I do
not care about the justice system at all
right I was like okay well I'm good at
math I'm going to be a computer
scientist
microeconomics looked at me and said
you [ __ ] skip this class after first
class I went up to the professor and I
was like yeah I'm gonna need to uh get
the [ __ ] out of here yeah yeah and he
was like yeah I know I know I can tell
then
I was like okay
literally you just asked me why there's
no plus and minus this in microeconomics
yeah [ __ ] where's the timetables this
is some [ __ ] then then I was like
okay so I'm gonna be an architect oh you
gotta know how to draw nope just too
many [ __ ] things no no then I was
like okay what do I like to do I like
music okay so I said okay I'm gonna be a
DJ so the school would let me be do the
DJ and stuff so for some reason for a
fluke I took a communications class
because I was like whatever first day in
that class they made us get up and see
if we could talk in front of class I
talked for like a 30 minutes and the
lady came over to she was like you don't
have to take this class she was like I'm
gonna go ahead and pass you she's like
you need to go and start taking more
classes like this because you know she's
like something's there you know I was so
at first I was like good for her I was
like okay well I'm gonna be a good DJ or
something or I'm gonna be like an
actress or something or like I never
thought comedian all this time I'm
making people laugh like crazy but I
never thought comedian I always thought
Oh Come median is like Richard Pryor
Whoopi Goldberg Eddie Murphy I'm not
that you know maybe I'll be an actress
and I'll get to play whoopee one day in
the movie that's that's as far as I
would go I don't know none of it was
really
I don't know like grabbing on I would do
these little things but I did notice
that I was at parties people were
inviting me to parties because I was
funny as [ __ ] and I was just you know so
I got us I got my scholarship changed
over to Colorado State my coach left
Chapman and then went to Colorado State
and took me with him but he didn't tell
me that it was going to be a red shirt
year I didn't know what red shirt was
until I got there and I was like oh I
have to practice but I can't [ __ ]
play the game [ __ ] this like I don't
want to do this and I was hanging out
with these girls and this girl signed me
up for a contest she signed me up for a
comedy contest on the campus funniest
person on campus and she came in one day
and she was like well we were walking
through the thing and she saw the sign
and she was like you should sign up for
that and I was like no what the [ __ ] is
wrong with she said like she's like
you're so [ __ ] funny [ __ ] you're so
funny I was like [ __ ] you don't know
what funny is because again I'm thinking
Richard Pryor right Whoopi Goldberg
Eddie Murphy you don't know what funny
is I'm I'm okay right she's like she
came to the my apartment like two days
later and she was like yo I signed you
up for that contest and I was like [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you like I'm
not gonna do that I'm not I was mad at
her but I wasn't angry angry and then I
was just like well you think I can do it
and she was like [ __ ] you are funny
just get up there and start talking so I
was like okay so I went to this contest
and you know how comedians are that hear
about a contest so all the comics from
Denver came down to Fort Collins and
tried to intimidate us this is the first
thing I learned you know but they don't
know that you know I'm from a [ __ ]
Hood where gangsters pimps hoes
crackheads I didn't seen everything so
you're not gonna pull one over on me but
I could see they were intimidating the
other Comics so I just went up and just
started talking about my family and
these and ripped won the contest but
I'ma tell you the process of walking on
that stage and touching the mic
was absolutely religious yeah I remember
touching the mic and thinking I have
been doing this all my life already yep
it literally felt like something that
was like it had been put on me it was a
perfect shirt I don't know if if that's
the same experience but I just remember
speaking into the mic going
oh I'm gonna be doing this for the rest
of my life well here's what I think I
can really what I can relate to and uh
which I know to be true is when when I
was growing up I made people around me I
made my family laugh I made my brothers
and sisters laugh big family I make kids
in the neighborhood laugh I make kids at
school laugh that was my secret weapon
and it got around that I was really
funny I I didn't think that counted I
thought that's just called yeah you're
funny with your friends and if someone
had ever said to me you should be funny
professionally I'd say well no no just
like what you said I'd say no funny
people that's something else like
professional comedians professional talk
show host professional anyone who's in
front of people and they're paying money
to see them and they're making them
laugh that's something very different I
don't know what that is and I'm a
thousand million miles away from that
that is what I thought and then when I
started getting up in front of people
and getting laughs it felt exactly the
same way like I was a duck being put
into water for the first time and going
wait this feels right this feels really
good but it still took years oh years
and years
47. I didn't make it till I was 47. I
think I was comfortable with doing
comedy but you know when you first start
comedy and this is what I tell new jacks
just first of all real Comics we hate
when people come up to us and ask hey
what advice do you have for new Comics
because the first thing I'm gonna say is
quit yeah because if you got to ask
right now then you [ __ ] you're not
going to hang in there to do what you
have to do but it still took years for
me to learn how to actually perform yeah
you know until I saw Jamie Foxx I was
just wailing out there just I didn't
know that you have to write jokes that
fit you you don't just write jokes you
know what I'm saying so I was going up
there saying [ __ ] that did not people
were like who
what like what are you talking about
like I would get booed I was getting I
would just get scratched off by the DJ I
saw Jamie Foxx one night and he
performed and I was like oh my God
that's okay that's the form of Comedy
that's that's what I want to do okay so
how because I I didn't think anyone
could be funnier than Richard Pryor or
Eddie Murphy or Whoopi Goldberg like I
said I had put them in that and to see
someone perform in that same same genre
of like I was like oh mannerisms and
[ __ ] I was like oh this is it this is oh
[ __ ] I remember getting my friend to
talk to his friends so I can talk to him
and yeah but he was like you don't have
[ __ ] to talk about you know you're a
youngster I was like 18. he was like you
he was like go get [ __ ] go [ __ ]
someone go get your heart bro go break
some hearts go get fired go get hired
just go and live life so you can have
some material and I just knew I had that
wanting in me and I was more scared of
not going up than going up yeah so it
was that but I knew that I didn't want
to do it until I was good at it so
that's what I did I went six years and
live life
had crazy times and then came back in 93
and just been doing it ever since